você sabia que existe uma recomendação
meio escondida nos aparelhos que
aconselha a manter o telefone uma certa
distância do nosso corpo isso para
limitar a exposição à radiofrequência e
garantir que fiquemos dentro dos limites
de segurança se você é do tipo que
guarda o celular no bolso ou até mesmo
no sutiã ou costuma colar o aparelho no
ouvido para conversar então está indo na
direção errada contra essa recomendação
e isso pode ter consequências pra saúde
que ainda não são totalmente Claras
Afinal os estudos realizados nos últimos
10 anos sobre a relação a radiação
eletromagnética dos celulares e o risco
de câncer tem resultados variados e
conflitantes e atualmente ainda não há
um consenso sobre esse tema se tem o
nível de risco é grande ou pequeno ou
nulo que o uso de celulares representa
nessa incerteza podemos tomar alguns
cuidados simples para evitar e Minimizar
riscos procure não carregar o celular
colado ao corpo e também o tempo todo e
deixe no modo avião se que que for
possível Além disso evite dormir com ele
perto da cama e tente desligá-lo à noite